jessica's with us in wyoming hi Jessica
how are you Oh better than I deserve
what's up I'm sorry I can't hear you
speak directly into your phone I'm sorry
try again yes ma'am okay starting me
step to about halfway through we have
movie night out of the doors of goods
between credit cards and vehicle and
luckily she was I'm fully covered
medically through the VA a being
service-connected my child will not be
they will no my husband's insurance and
we never having had insurance to Blue
Cross Blue Shield I was thinking saving
about 7,000 so something saving
something good debt what is your what is
your household income a hundred thousand
good how old are you - I'm thirty here
34 okay cool what we recommend is when a
baby's on the way you stop your Total
Money Makeover you stop the baby steps
just push pause pile up as much cash as
you can pile up okay during the nine
months or in this case seven months
remaining right yep okay so during the
seven months how much do you think you
can save if you just don't pay any act
you pay minimum payments on your debts
you live on a budget and all the money
that you would have used to reduce debt
we're gonna pile it up in a savings
account how much would you have in seven
months probably close to twenty thousand
great okay now let's run that scenario
out baby baby comes mom and baby are
both okay insurance does what it's
supposed to do there's no hiccups and
mom and baby come home how much of that
twenty thousand would have come out of
your pocket to pay for this labor and
delivery that is fully covered
zero so unless there's a problem with
the child of some kind you would have
zero out of
right correct okay so you come home you
and baby come home there's $20,000 in
the savings account you take 19 of it
and you put it on your debt snowball
okay and you restart you push play again
on your baby step two baby steps and
rock on through what you have lost by
doing that is whatever you would have
saved in interest on the debt you
reduced during seven months on 19,000
which isn't spit okay
interest isn't the problem okay on this
because it's a short-term thing and
you're just piling up cash and there is
something very comforting about a big
warm pile of cash when you're going
through a medical procedure you've never
been through before like having your
first child I agree a hundred percent
that's why I was a little nervous and
scared I'd be a lot of nervous I just
pushed pause and then push play my point
is if you stay on your budget and you
stay again you do exactly what you would
have done in terms of sacrificing and
saving instead of sacrificing and paying
down debts you're gonna end up seven
months from now and almost exactly the
same place when you write the check when
the baby and you come home okay you're
really not gonna lose any ground by
doing this when you push play again now
if you screw around and you relax and
you use some of this money to decorate
the nursery and all this kind of stuff
then you've messed this planet that's
not what I'm talking about now we're
putting on buying everything you see
what I'm saying there's a lot of ways
you can screw this up if you treat this
money like it was already paid on the
debt and you only use it if there's some
kind of a need for you or the child
medically okay if there's not I expect
all of that money to still be in that
freaking account okay got that okay now
we're getting dialed in good
hey thanks and congratulations very cool
stuff